[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مذكرات وزير الخارجيه ومدير
السي اي ايه السابق في عهد الرئيس ترامب
مذكرات تستحق القراءه
ولكنها قراءه يجب ان تكون حذره ليه قراءه
حاذره لان ما يكون لم يكتب مذكرات رجل
يتقاعد ويودع العمل السياسي وهذه شهادته
الاخيره على تجربته بل مذكرات سياسي يرغب
في العوده للعمل العام ويرغب في العوده من
اوسع ابواب العمل العام السياسي لانه اعرض
عن رغبته في الترشح للرئاسه الامريكيه في
انتخابات 24
ومن يقرا المذكرات اللي صدرت فيهم 24
يناير الماضي يدرك ببساطه ان هذه المذكرات
ليست الا جزء من حمله انتخابيه مبكرا
ولانها جزء من حمله انتخابيه مبكرا فهو
كان حريص جدا ان يصلي الضوء على
طاعته كسياسي
وبيسلط الضوء على صوره ذهنيه معينه له
كرجل سياسه وهي صوره السياسي الصلب جدا
الذي لا يتهاون ابدا في حقوق الامريكان
ومصالحهم القوميه ولذلك جائع عنوان
المذكرات نيفر جفانينش فايتنج فور ذي
امريكا اي لف لا تتهاون في شبر واحد
القتال من اجل امريكا التي احب
ولانه برده المذكرات جزء من حمله انتخابيه
مبكرا
فالكتاب العدد صفحات 450 صفحه الثيم
الاساسي في او الموضوع الاساسي فيه هو
الهجوم الشرس جدا على خصومه خصومه الذي
سوف يلتقيهم على الارجح في الانتخابات
المقبله ومن هم خصومه الاجابه المختصره
جدا الديمقراطيين الاجابه الاوسع انه
اختار تعبيرا لوصفهم طوال صفحات الكتاب
وهو اليسار المتقدم لفت ما هو البرجراف
المختصره مره اخرى الليبراليين او
الديمقراطيين لكن الاجابه الاوسع تقتدي ان
نعرف انها جناح داخل الحزب الديمقراطي
الجناح ده متطرف جدا من وجهه نظره على
الاقل كجمهوري كايامين محافظ متطرفين جدا
في الدفاع عن قضايا حقوق الانسان في
الدفاع عن العولمه في الدفاع عن
البيئه الى اخره طب وايه مشكلته معاهم هو
كميل محافظ بيمثل الطرف الاخر تماما كل ما
يذهبون اليه هو بيذهب في الطرف الاخر يعني
مثلا دفعهم عن البيئه تعني رفدهم او وضع
قيود على الاستثمار في الوقود الاحفوري
اللي هو كيميل محافظ جزء من اجننتته
الاستثمار الاكثر في الوقود الاحفوري
وبالتالي عدم الحماس لقضايا التغير
المناخي والحفاظ على البيئه لما بيتكلموا
على العولمه معناها حريه تدفق في الاموال
الامريكيه للاسواق الخارجيه وده من وجهه
نظره بيضر الطبقه المتوسطه والعامله في
امريكا اللي بتحرم من فرص العمل لما
بيدافع كتير برده عن الحقوق الانسان
بمعناه الواسع فيها مشكلتين الاول انها
دعمه للمهاجرين اللي بياتو الى الولايات
المتحده وهو ليس متحمسا كيميني محافظ
للمهاجرين ويرغب في وضع ضوابط لها الامر
الاخطر انه حماس همم اليسار المتقدم
ليه حقوق الاقليات اللي بيسموها الواو
كالتشر اللي هي يعني توجه جديد وذا يستحق
ان يتوقف عنده في حلقه مقبله بيذهبوا
بعيدا جدا في مراعاه حقوق كل الاقليات
الجنسيه والعرقيه
وطبعا الدينيه وده بالنسبه له هو كمين
محافظ يعني ينتقص وينتهج ويضعف هويه البلد
اللي هو كميل محافظ يرغب في الحفاظ عليها
هويه البلد دي ايه امريكا البيضاء
المسيحيه الى اخره
قصه طويله بس اللي يعنينا منها في هذه
الحلقه انه اليمين اليسار التقدمي
وبالمناسبه كلمه يسار تقدمي ليست محل
اجماع في تعريفها يعني لو سالت 10 اساتذه
متخصصين في الولايات المتحده ربما يعتوك
اجابات مختلفه قليلا كل منهم يعطي اجابه
تختلف عن الاخر انما القاسم المشترك بين
هذه القوه
انهم معنيين جدا بحقوق الانسان
وبشكل متطرف وليست الحقوق الاساسيه كما
اشرت لحضراتكم
وضعوا في اذهانكم وهو بيستخدم كلمه اليسار
المتقدم
مش بس للاشاره الى هؤلاء في داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي ولكن كلمه عامه بيضع فيها كل
خصومه وسبقوا لنفس الاستخدام الرئيس ترامب
يعني الناس اللي موجودين في الحزب
الديمقراطي الصحفيين الكبار والناشئين
اللي
بينحازوا اليهم اليهم مراكز الابحاث الى
اخره على العموم
دي قصه يطول شرحها لكن ما يعني ايه هنا في
هذه المذكرات انه في اطار رغبته في تلميع
صورته كسياسي استثنائي وفي همم اطار رغبته
في الهجوم على خصومه استشهد باحداث كثيره
والقى الدول على احداث كثيره في صفحات
المذكرات التي تعنينا نحن هنا في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط ومن الطريف جدا انه اكثر
حادثه
اثارت الجدل داخل الولايات المتحده كانت
تتعلق بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط بامتياز وهي
حادثه مقتل جمال خاشقجي الصحفي السعودي في
اكتوبر 2018
القصه عرضها في اطار ايه هو اعراضها في
الصفحه 63
وتحت عنوان خاشقجي كريز او جنون حادثه
خاشقجي هو كان بيتحدث عن
رغبه ادارته في تصحيح اخطاء الاداره
السابقه اللي هي اداره اوباما اللي طبعا
طوال الوقت هو بيهاجمها وبيهاجم الاداره
اللائحه المماثله لها اداره بيض طبعا
وبيقول ان هم
ارتكبوا مجموعه من الاخطاء منها توقيعهم
لاتفاق النووي مع ايران وان احنا كان يجب
ان نصالح هذا الخطا بالخروج من هذا
الاتفاق الذي يصب في صالح النظام الايراني
الشرير ووصف طبعا النظام الايراني بيحضن
به مساحه هائله جدا من المذكرات وكل ما
يقوله طبعا عن ايران باعتبارها معقل الشر
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والعالم
وبيصف الاتفاقيه اللي ابرمها اوباما في
2015 واعتبر احد اهم انجازاته بانها
اتفاقيه عافنه طيب
في اطار حديثه عن خروجه من هذه الاتفاقيه
بيقول احنا بعد ما خرجنا قررنا ان نطلب من
النظام الايراني هنخرج من هذه الاتفاقيه
لانها مع عيبه ونرغب في ان تاتي الينا
ونتفاوض على اتفاقيه جديده بما ان
الايرانيين رفضوا فكانوا الامريكان اداره
ترامب
والسيد همم
باعتباره احد اقتبها مستعدين
بحزمه من العقوبات سموها يعني حزمه عقوبات
غير مسبوقه لاجبارهم على المجيء اجبار
الايرانيين على المجيء والجلوس على مائده
المفاوضات مره اخرى
وبيقول في صفحه 63 انه تنفيذ هذه العقوبات
بشكل فعال كان يقتدي ان نقيب علاقات مع كل
دول العالم لكن اليسار اللي انا اشرت اليه
كرهنا لاننا والثقنا علاقاتنا مع دول شرق
اوسطيه سجلها في حقوق الانسان ديسمم يعني
سيء
واعتبر هو انه غضب اليسار
بالمعنى اللي انا شرحته ده
لتوفيق علاقتنا بدول شرقه او سطيه لان
سجلها في حقوق الانسان مظلم نوع من التابل
ستاندرد او المعايير المزدوجه لان هو
بيقول ان اداره اوباما ارادت ان تقيم
علاقات مع ايران بل وتجعلها حجر الزاويه
لسياسه الولايات المتحده في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط فلماذا يلومون ترامب او الجمهوريين
او هو كوزير خارجيه على توفيق علاقاته
بدول الشرق الاوسط الاخرى اللي مهما كان
سجلها في حقوق الانسان سيء فلن تكون اسوا
من ايران من ناحيه مع وجود فرقه مهم جدا
الفرق ده هو اللي بيقوله او فرقين الفرق
الاول انه هذه الانظمه الاخرى
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط راغبه في التعاون
مع امريكا في ما ان ايران ترغب في تدمير
امريكا الامر الثاني انه
اوباما اراد ان يقيم علاقات عميقه مع
ايران اذا نجحت اذا كانت فكرته قد نجحت
اللي هو
الاعتماد على ايران
كحجر الزاويه في السياسه الامريكيه واللي
كان الاساس فيها توقيع الاتفاقيه النوويه
فيما انه علاقات الرئيس ترامب ووزير
خارجاتهمبيه وكانت رمزي اكشنلل كانت يعني
علاقه نفعيه جدا مع دول الشرق الاوسط
الاخرى دول الخليج مصر المغرب الجزائر كل
الدول العلاقات التركيه حتى
اكشنلل ما يعني انهم قد يتعاونوا معها في
قضايا وقد لا يتعاونوا معها في قضايا اخرى
في هذا الاطار بيقول انه اليسار اللي
كرهنا لاننا وثقنا علاقتنا بدول في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط كان اكثر غضبا على وجه
التحديد من العلاقات المتميزه بيننا
وبيننا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وقال تعبير لطيف قال انه علاقتنا بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
جعلت اليسار التقدم اللي انا اشرت اليه ده
مثل رجل نباتي او شخص نباتي تم دفعه الى
مسلخ للحيوانات ودا التعبير اللي استخدمه
كانوا منزعجين جدا وهذا الانزعاج انفجر
طبعا ليه احنا تكلمنا عن القصه انه
العلاقات بين المؤسسات الامريكيه اللي هي
منتهيه لليسار يعني معنيه اوي
يعني حقوق الانسان العلاقه مش عظيمه قوي
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه وده خصصنا له
حلقات سابقه كثيره يعني
انما هؤلاء يعني
ظهر دقهم في
اقصى صوره بعد مقتل الصحفي السعودي كمال
خاشقجي ومن هنا بدا يتحدث عن قصه مقتل
جمال خاشقجي القصه بيبداها بيقول انها
بدات في يوم اثنين اكتوبر 2018 عندما
استدرج مجموعه من العملاء السعوديين
الجمال خاشقجي في قنصليه السعوديه في
اسطنبول بتركيا
وقتلوه وقطعوه وقال ان هذه الجريمه طبعا
كانت جريمه بشعه هو مش وصفها بس بكده ده
هو وصفها بانها كانت
او تريجس انا كسبت بالحروفك سادس بكبل
ايفل الى اخره جريمه
شائنه مروعه حزينه شريره الى اخره
بالاضافه الى انها غير قانونيه
لكن هذه الحادثه على رغم قبحها لم تكن
مفاجاه على الاقل بالنسبه اليه ده هو اللي
بيتكلم
لقد رايت ما يكفي من الشرق الاوسط لاعرف
ان هذا النوع من القسوه العنيفه
كان معتادا جدا في هذا الجزء من العالم
هذا لا يجعل مقتله مقبولا لكن رد فعل
الكثيرين
كانت مصطنعه جدا ومبالغ فيها وذكرتني ده
هو يعني اللي بيقول رد فعل الشرطي اللي
موجود في فيلم كازابلانكا فيلم ابيض واسود
امريكي قديم هذا الشرطي كان اعتاد انه
يذهب الى ملهى مش بس بيرتدوا كل يوم بل
بيقامر في كل يوم ما يعني انه يعلم جيدا
انه هذا المقهى او هذا الملهى بيمارس نشاط
الجنب لينج او القمار ثم جاءته في يوم من
الايام من رؤسائه امرا باخلاق المقهى ذهب
الى اغلاق المقهى وطلب من كل الجلسرين ان
يخرجوا لما سالوا صاحب الملهى على اي اساس
انت ترغب في اغلاق المقهى رد بتلقائه
مضحكه
جدا جدا
وعشان يبقى المشهد
عبثيه بينما هو بيقول الكلام ده بياتيه
احد موظفي صاله القمار وبيقول له ارباحك
عن مضاربتك او عن قمارك في الليله السابقه
يا سيدي وباضعها في جيبه وبيستانف اندهاشه
من وجود قمار في هذه الصاله الخلاصه انه
بنطيبه وكل الاعلام والقوى القوى اليسار
اللي ثارت على مقتل جمال خاشقجي ما انتم
عارفين ان هذا هي الطريقه التي بتطاهر بها
الامور في منطقه الشرق الاوسط فلما كل هذا
الانتهاش على العموم
بيتابع السيد بومبيو في
الكتاب وبيقول انه القصه دي قصه مقتل جمال
خاشقجي اخذت ابعاد اكثر دراميه
لانه صحفي بين قوسين في في عرف القانون في
عرف الدول
بتطبق الديمقراطيه الصحفي لا يجب المساس
به مش لانه اهم من غيره ولكن هم بيعاملون
زي ما بيعامله مثلا رجال الاسعاف في مواقع
القتال دول المفروض لا يتم المساس بهم سهل
لهم القيام بعملهم دي معلومه مهمه عشان
لان هو طوال الوقت لما بيقول هذا ليس
صحافيا او هذا صحفيا يبقى لها دلاله معينه
انه لا يجب الاضرار به
بيقول القصه اخذت ابعادا اكثر دراميه من
جانب الاعلام الامريكي ومن يقف ورائه لان
جمال خاشقجي كان صحفيا ولن يكونوا واضحين
ده هو اللي بيقولوا ده امريكان صادم من
مسؤول امريكي واول مره حد يتكلم بالشكل
كده بهذا الشكل عن جمال خاشقجي وبيقول
جمال خاشقجي لم يكن صحفيا الا بقدر انا ما
اكون صحفيا انا وغيري من الشخصيات العامه
نكتب في الصحف ولكن لنا وظائف اخرى
وكتابتنا في الصحف لا تجعلنا صحفيين بل
سياسيين رجال مخابرات الى اخره لكن انا
لست صحفيين محترفين
وبيقول ان جمال خاشقجي كان في حقيقه الامر
نشط سياسي وليس صحفيا
وانه كان جزء من معركه او صراع دائر على
السلطه في السعوديه وانه كان يقف في الطرف
الخاسر في هذا الصراع على العرش السعودي
وانه كان غير سعيدا بنفيه من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ثم انه كان على علاقه
حميمه بجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
التي تدعم الارهاب وفقا لتعبيره بل انه
عبر علنا عن حزنه لوفاه اسامه بن لادن
وبيقول لم يكن يستحق الموت لكننا بحاجه ان
نكون واضحين بشان هويته ولم تكن كثير من
وسائل الاعلام واضحه في هذا الشان وبعدين
بيذهب الى ابعد من ذلك ويقول انه بعد ما
اقتله
بدات حمله هستيريه قادتها واشنطن بوست
لتدمير العلاقات الامريكيه السعوديه
وركزت هذه الحمله على شخصيه محمد بن سلمان
وبيقول انه اليسار التقدم اللي انا اشرت
اليه يكره محمد بن سلمان
على الرغم من ان هذا الرجل اللي هو محمد
بن سلمان يقود اكبر اصلاح ثقافي في تاريخ
المملكه وسوف يثبت انه احد اهم القاده في
عصره
وشخصيه تاريخيه حقا على المسرح العالمي
وبيذهب
ليقول انه او يستانف ليقول انه الحمله
اللي قضيتها وسائل الاعلام كان لها اثار
بعيده حتى على
شخصيات مؤثره داخل الحزب الجمهوري ومنهم
لينسجرام السيناتور المهم جدا اللي اعلم
بسبب هذه الحمله الكبيره وتاثره بها انه
لن يتعامل ابدا مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولن يتحدث معها الا اذا تم تدمير
محمد بن سلمان
بيقول ده دفعني ان انا اتصل به واقول له
يا سيد الانسجرام احنا تعاملنا مع بعض
واشتغلنا كثير مع بعض
هل انت تطلب من اداره ترامب ان تجعل من
تغيير النظام في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
سياسه رسميا هل تطالبنا بذلك فرد وقال
مايك داتس باد هذا امر سوف يكون سيء جدا
وهذا امر سيء جدا وبعدين هو اضعف من عنده
ان الانسجرام
كان يعلم في اعماقه اننا لا نستطيع ولا
ينبغي قطع العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اللي اشار فيه كثير من اجزاء
الكتاب الى اهميتها الكبيره جدا
لمصالح همم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بيقول ان الرئيس ترامب في ذروه الاحداث
طلب مني ان اذهب وان اقابل ولي العهد وقال
له مايك
ابلغ ولي العهد انه ما دين لنا طبعا مدين
اللي انا بايه يقصد ان احنا دعمناه في وجه
هذه العاصفه بقول ذهبت وقابلته وسوف يظل
محتوى مقابله مع الامير محمد
يعني سرا لكني اكتفي بان اقول اننا ركزنا
في هذا المقابله السريه على الحفاظ على
مصالح الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وبيشير الى الى انه بعد مقابته ل ولي
العهد وهو كان اول مسؤول يلتقي الامير
محمد بعد هذه الحادثه المذله
ركزت كل وسائل الاعلام على صورته مع
الامير محمد باعتبار التقيت الرجل الرجل
الذي اختزله في قتل جمال خاشقجي وبيقول
هناك امرين لابد من التوضيحيهما الامر
الاول انه على عكس الشائع في الصحف وما
يتردد
لا توجد اي ادله من جانب المخابرات
الامريكيه على ربط الامير محمد مباشره
بقتل جمال خاشقجي يوم 2 اكتوبر 2018
وكل ما جاء في تقرير المخابرات الامريكيه
في الصادر في فبراير 2021 بعد ان جاء
الرئيس همم بيضين الى السلطه هو انه
بالتاكيد كان ان هم بيخمنوا انه يقينن رجل
في هذا المنصب وجريمه بهذا الحجم انه يعرف
وهذا لا يعد دليلا
ده كلام كمبيوتر الامر الثاني انه حتى لو
كان الامير محمد قد تورط فيه مقتله حتى هو
بيقول اداه شرط يعني
فقد التقيت كرجل المخابرات وكراجل سياسه
الكثير من الزعماء حول العالم الذين تورته
في جرائم من هذا النوع وهذا لا يعني ان
نقطع علاقتنا بكل دوله تورط صانع القرار
فيها في جريمه من هذا النوع
وبعدين بيقول انا فخور انا لم نتخذ قرارا
متسرعا وعاطفيا الى اخره وبيقول انه حادثه
جمال خاشقجي هذه كانت واحده من تجارب
الاولى في قياده وزاره الخارجيه
وعلمتني
القاعده او ذكرتني بالقاعده الشهيره التي
كنت قد سمعت عنها في تاريخ السياسي السابق
اذا انتظرت الخيار الامثل في السياسه
الخارجيه فانه لن ياتي ابدا انت دائما
بتعمل في ظروف صعبه وعليك ان تاخذ اقرب
خيار يمكن ان يخدم مصالح بلدك طيب
وطبعا
بيكرر في هذه الحادثه انه منطقه في هذا
اننا لا نعيش في عالم مثالي واننا نعيش في
عالم مين ناستي وعالم شرير ويعني مين
الناس تكرول ولد وقاسي وموحش جدا والثلاث
كلمات دول مين وناسه في العالم كلمات
متكرره كثيرا في صفحات الكتاب ولو كان
للمذكرات عنوان اخر كانت هتبقى انه عالم
شرير وقاسي طيب
هو تكلم عن ولي العهد الثاني يعني من
البلدان اللي اشار اليها كثير ولكن بشكل
ايجابي كانت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
طبعا مفيش دوله حظيت بنفس الاهتمام اللي
حظيت به ايران لكن السعوديه من الدول
التحدث عنها كثيرا ومره ثانيه بيتحدث عن
ولي العهد في الفصل ال 13 اللي حمل
العنوان تشوز درايه لايس وبيتناول فيه
الاتفاقات الابراهيميه اللي هي عقد سلام
من جانب اربع دول عربيه برعايه امريكيه
الامارات والبحرين والسودان والمغرب في
وقبل ما اتكلم هو اتقال ايه عن ولي العهد
فيما يتعلق بالاتفاقات الابراهيميه من
المهمه ان نتوقف عند هذه الاتفاقات هو لم
يضع فيها سرا ولكن اشار اليها باعتبارها
انجاز عظيم كده ما كان ليتم لولا اراده
الله اراده الله ده مش انا اللي بقوله ده
تعبير هو وبيقول لم يكن احد ليصدق ابدا
لولا اراده الله وتوفيقه ان الطيارين
الاماراتيين والطيرين الاسرائيليين يكونون
في السماء ليس للاشتباك ولكن لتشكيل سربن
في مناورات عسكريه مشتركه وقال ان هذه
الاتفاقات ما كانت لتتم لولا مجموعه من
العوامل واحد منها الخطر اللي بيهدد الخطر
المشترك اللي بيهدد كثيرا من دول المنطقه
اسرائيل ودول الخليج على وجه التحديد وهي
ايران وسياستها الشريره كما يصفها دائما
الامر الثاني رؤيه الثاقبه لاداره ترامب
وطبعا فيها اشاره ضمنيه له ايه الفرق
بيقول الاداره ديه رات شيئا لم تره
الادارات السابقه وخصوصا اداره
الديمقراطيين اوباما
في الثمان سنوات السابقه
الادارات السابقه اللي بيصفها
الديمقراطين وخصومه من اليسار
بعدم الكفاءه والجبن اللي مبللين لفرشهم
والمفصلين عن الواقع كانوا دائما
الشرق الاوسط من المنظور اليهود والعرب
اسرائيل وكل الدول الاخرى فيما ان احنا
راينا ان الزمن قد تجاوز هذه التقسيمات
وبدانا نرى المنطقه في اطار اخر هذا
الاطار يمكن ان نتجاوز فيه هذه التقسيمه
ويمكن ان يتحقق السلام بين اسرائيل وبين
دول العربيه مختلفه دون
يعني
قامت دوله فلسطينيه بعد ان نتجاوز
الفلسطينيين ليه الا ان المنطقه بقت بفضل
ايران منقسمه الى
معسرين معسكر السلام وده بتقف في اسرائيل
والدول العربيه معينه ومعسكر الدمار اللي
بتقوده ايران
واضرعها والارهاب السني داعش والقاعده
وبالمناسبه هو قال لاحقا في صفحات اخرى ان
ايران هي المقر الرئيسي للقاعده ودي طبعا
لم تكن اول مره يقولها واحد يعني سياسي
ولا حاجه يتقالت قبل كده لكن كان دائما
بينتقدوا انهم لم يقدموا ما يكفي من
الادله لكن هو مصر على ان هذا امر سليم
وبيدلل على كده بانه التقارير
الاستخباراتيه التي صدرت في عهد الرئيس
بيدن بتاكد نفس الكلام
على العموم وهو بيتكلم عن الاتفاقات
الابراهيميه اشاد بشده
بالشيخ محمد بن زايد واشاده بشده بالشيخ
طحنون بن زايد وتحدث يعني باعجاب كبير
عنهما ثم اشار الى ولي العهد الامير محمد
وقال ان احنا كنا قريبين جدا من ان تصبح
السعوديه الدوله الخامسه التي تقيم علاقات
مع
اسرائيل لكن
القرار النهائي في هذه الامور كان لجلاله
الملك همم سلمان وانه وقتها هو يعني يوحي
بانه بان الامير محمد الذي لم تكن هذا من
صلاحياتي لم يكن يومان وانه اعطى موافقته
الضنيه على الاتفاقات الابراهيميه الاخرى
للبحرين والامارات والمغرب
والسودان الى اخره وان العالم يجب ان يكون
مدين له لانه
ليس من السهل على همم يعني همم حاكم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان يبارك
اتفاقات سلام مع اسرائيل طبعا من المهمه
ان اذكر ان روايه السيد بومبيو تظل روايه
السيد بومبي وعدد من المسؤولين الامريكان
فيما يتعلق بالموقف الشخصي لولي العهد
السعودي من التطبيع على مع التطبيع مع
اسرائيل لكن الموقف المعلن لولي العهد
والموقف الرسمي للمملكه انه لا تضيع مع
اسرائيل الا بعد اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
بعد كده
بيشير في الفصل ال 14 اللي هي التراينج نو
ايديس الى همم
همم الرئيس السيسي طب انا ليه قلت الرئيس
السيسي بعد الامير محمد لان هو اللي عمل
الربط وقال ثاني اهم ثاني اكثر سياسي في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط لحظه بكراهيت
واستهجان اليسار التقدمي هو الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي اللي هو اللي بيقول
اللي اصبح شريكا رئيسيه للولايات المتحده
في الحرب على الارهاب وتحدث في يعني فقرات
قليله عن الوضع اللي كان موجود عليه مصر
عندما جاؤوا الى الاداره وقالوا ان مصر
كانت خرجت بعد 2013 و2014 من تجربه او
يعني من اول 2011 من تجربه يعني مرهقه جدا
امنيا وقال ان كان لها وضع خاص الوضع
الخاص ديه ان مصر وضع خاص بالنسبه
للامريكان ان مصر بلد فيه 100 مليون وقتها
مصر الان اكثر من 100 مليون وعلى حدود
اسرائيل قلب خاصه اللي هي اكثر ما يعني
الامريكان في المنطقه
وجنوب البحر المتوسط اي جنوب الاتحاد
الاوروبي اهم شركاء الولايات المتحده
وعلى حدود ملتهبه مع غزه حيث توجد حماس
وعلى ليبيا حيث الانفلات الامني منذ سقوط
معمر القذافي ثم انها تجلس على ممر مشهور
جدا لعبور الارهابيين من افريقيا الى حيث
شاؤوا في الشمال هو بيقول انه التقى
الرئيس السيسي لاول مره حين كان وزير
الاندفاع في مارس 2014 وفي هذا اليوم
الالتقاه في بومبيه مع شخصيتين اخرىيتين
من مجتمع الاستخبارات الامريكي اخبرهم
السيسي بمعلومتين المعلومه الاولانيه انه
يعتزموا الترشح لرئاسه الدوله في اليوم
التالي وبيقول لهم ان هذا يعني انكم اذا
قررتم زيارته في العام المقبل فسوف
تجدونني في احد احتمالا احتمال الاول انني
اقود دوله مزدهره اقتصاديا والاحتمال
الثاني ان اكون في السجن مع الرئيسين
السابقين همم اللي هو رئيس مبارك والرئيس
مرسي
والمعلومه الثانيه اللي طرحها والموضوع
الثاني المهم اللي طرحه هو رغبته في ان
يساعده مصر في الحصول على
مروحيات اباتشي اللي كانت اداره اوباما قد
جمرت هذه الصفقه يعني مصر اشترت مروحيات
الاباتشي واداره اوباما مجمده تسليم
الاباتشي كنوع من العقوبات على مصر
لانتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وبيقول لهم ان انا في حاجه الى هذه
المروحيات في حرب على الارهاب وبيتضامن
معكم وبيقول من الغريب جدا ان اا تقوم
اداره امريكيه بعقاب دوله بحرمانها من
وسائلها لقتال الارهابيين اللي هم عدو
لمصر كما انه عدو لامريكا ولباقي دول
العالم
تحدث بعد ذلك بومبيو كثيرا جدا عن ايران
لكن انا اتوقف عن
يعني
عند حادثه او عند جزء معين يعني لان اظن
انه بقيه الاجزاء اولا يطول شرحها جدا
وكثير منها تقدر تختصره في النيران هي
مصدر كل شرور في هذا العالم
انما هو تحدث عن اغتيال قاسم سليماني وفي
الصفحه 148 بيقول انه قتل هذا الجنرال
اللي هو كان بيقود فيلق القدس التابع
للحرس الثوري اللي مسؤول عن العمليات
الخارجيه لايران يعني
ايه ذكر لاول مره او طرح لاول مره كفكره
على الرئيس ترامب في 29
ديسمبر 2019 لما كنت انا ده هو اللي بيقول
كوزير خارجيه مجلس مع وزير الدفاع ومع
رئيس هيئه الاركان في بيت الرئيس ترامب في
فلوريدا وانه قلنا له كده يا سياده الرئيس
احنا جايين لك في عمل انجاز لدينا توصيه
مهمه الهدف هو الجنرال قاسم سليمان وبيقول
ان القصه ديت في اطار انه احنا كنا همم
يعني بناخذ قرارات جريئه جدا ما كان
لهؤلاء الجبناء من اليسار
التقدمي ان يفكر فيها لانهم قليل الكفاءه
وجبناء كانوا مش هيفكروا ابدا في ان
يذهبوا الى راس الافعى كما يعني يصفه
الكثير من الامريكان اللي هو الجنرال قسم
سليماني
وبيقول انه الرجل اللي قتل يوم 3 يناير
2020 في طريقه الى مطار بغداد بعد لقائه
لرئيس الوزراء العراقي
بيقول انه
احنا ليه قتلناه
طب دي اهميتها ايه ما هو معروفه مليئه وما
هو عدوهم لا ما هو كان عدوهم لسنوات سابقه
لكن كان احد اسباب عدم امتناع اي اداره
امريكيه عن استهدافه واحد ان ده سوف يفتح
عليهم ابواب الجحيم معه يا رب وده اللي
بيسخر منه اثنين بيسخر منه لان احنا
امريكا وهم ايران نحن اقوى اثنين انه ماذا
سوف يفيد الامريكان اذا قتلوا قاسم سليمان
لا ايه ده ذهب قاسم سوف ياتي قاسم سليمان
اخر هو بيقول لا ده ما كانش منطقه اولا
نحن في وضع الاقوى وبالتالي يمكننا ان
نصاعد ولا نخشى من تصعيدي ده وجهه نظر
الامر الثاني انه اذا قتل قاسم سليمان فمن
الصعب ان تجد ايران قاسم سليمان اخر وقال
ان هذا الرجل
كان بيجمع مزيج من
الباور السلطه القوه الموجوده في يديه
اللي اتخذها بشخصه مش بمصيبه
والذكاء والوحشيه والكاريزما داخل ايران
محاوله استبداله مثل محاوله
تقليد لوحه لرامبنت ترامب برنت داء الرسام
الهولندي الشهيد في القرن ال 17 واحد اهم
رسامين في تاريخ الانسان
عاوز تقلد لوحه لرامبرنت جودلاك ربنا
يوفقك لكن صعب جدا ان تاتي بلوحه مقلده
تشبه الاصل وبالتالي يصعب ان تاتي بقسم
سليمان يعني اخر ثم وبالتالي اذا ذهب قاسم
ده وجهه نظره سوف تتاثر ايران كثيرا
ويبدو انه كان على صافي هذه المساله
بيقول في صفحه 162 انه اضعلومتين ان احنا
قبل مقتل السليماني ابلغنا حلفائنا في
المنطقه دول العربيه وتحديد الاسرائيل
لانه ربا حتى تستعد لانها ربما تكون الهدف
التالي لاى عمليا انتقاليه من جانب ايران
الامر الثاني اللي بيقول انني منذ مقتل
قسم سليماني في يناير
2020 والى الان حتى بعد خروجه من السلطه
لا استطيع ان استمتع بحياه خاصه كما كنت
افعل لانني دائما ملاحق به يعني همم
بامن كثيف يعني انا عندي حمايه امنيه
كبيره لان انا ندرك ان ايران قادره على
الرد حتى داخل الاراضي الامريكيه وبيدي
بعض التفاصيل في كده لا استطيع ان اقود
سيارتي بنفسي لا استطيع ان اذهب الى
السوبر ماركت الى اخره طبعا العلاقه مع
اسرائيل تحدث عنها بس لو عاوز تختصر كل
اللي قاله اسرائيل هو طبعا قناعته الدينيه
هو مسيحي انجيلي متدين جدا دائما كان
بيفخر انه يضع الانجيل امامه ان الانجيل
يعني هو الذي يحركه في كل تصرفاته كسياسه
ولانه مسيحي انجيلي فتفسيره لكثير من ايات
الانجيل بتجعل اسرائيل واليهود هم محور
هذا الكون من البدايه الى النهايه فعنده
عشق
وعشق شخص وثقافي وديني باسرائيل وحب لهذا
البلد اضيف اليه اعجاب بكثير من المسؤولين
وامنهم يوسف وهيل اللي هو كان رئيس
الموساد وقتها وتحدث كثيرا عن هذا يعني
اعجابا بكل تصرفاته من اول وسامته اللي
بيقول شهدت زوجته على وسامته يعني قدراته
كسباي او جاسوس الى اخره
انما لا يهمني في القصه هنا لان التفاصيل
كثيره في الفصل الثاني بعنوان
»
اللي بيقول انه جاءته مكالمه لم يحدد
وقتها من يوسف وهين اللي هو رئيس
المخابرات الموساد رئيس الموساد اييي رئيس
الموساد بيقول له في مكالمه بينما كان
يهبط من طائرته في احد الدول الاوروبيه
مايك كان لدينا فريق
في مهمه بالغه الاهميه والان اواجه بعض
الصعوبات في اخراج بعضهم هل يمكنني الحصول
على المساعده بيقول لم اضف لم اطرح اي
اسئله لم ااه افكر في اي في اي مخاطر
تواصلت مباشره بعد المكالمه مع رجال في كل
مكان في العالم وتوصلنا مع فريق الموساد
وفي خلال 24 ساعه كان عملاء الموساد قد
تم اخراجهم من هذا البلد
امنين بعد ان تمت واحده من اكبر العمليات
السريه التي تم اجرائها على الاطلاق
الاشاره قبلها وبعدها واثنائها بتشير الى
ما حدث
في فبراير 2018 اللي هو سرقت الارشيف
النووي الايراني وبعد كده بيقول كلام كثير
هائل يعني يعني يستحق التوقف عنده على حجم
التعاون بين المساد
والسي اي اي الى درجه انه بيقول ان هو
يوسف وهنا استضفني عنده في الموساد وجامع
كبار مسؤوليه وقال لهم سوف نتعامل بانكشاف
وتعاون كامل مع السي اي اي لا احد يحدثني
عن الايجو او الخصوصيه او السريه او سوف
نعمل وكاننا جهاز واحد وسوف اقوم بفصل اي
مسؤول في الموساد لا يتبع اوامر فيما
يتعلق بالتعاون الكامل مع السي اي اي
بيقول وانا استضاف في لانجري او في السي
اي اي مقر السي اي اي وفعلت نفس الشيء
كانهم جهاز واحد طيب
نقطه ثانيه مهمه انه تحدث في هذه المذكرات
عن سبب الخلافه الرئيسي بين تركيا وبين
الولايات المتحده وقال ان المساله الخلاف
بدا حين اصبحت داعش قوه مسيطره على اراضي
سوريا واراضي العراق ولما جاءت الاداره
الامريكيه
في 2017 كان التخلص من داع من داعش يعني
هدف رئيسي لا انا خصوصا في سوريا وكان
قدامنا واحد من اختيارين الاختيار الاول
ان ان نسلح الجامعات الكرديه اللي هي جسد
اللي موجوده في شمال سوريا على وجه
التحديد واا نساعدهم لضرب هذه الجماعات
والمقترح الثاني كانت تقدمت به تركيا
وخلاصته
ان هم اكثر قدره على التخلص والتعامل مع
هذه الجماعات المتطرفه بيقول انه
احنا رفضنا المقترح التركي لسببهم سبب
يتعلق كنت انا مهتم به انا وماك مستر اللي
هو اللي هو هو كوزير خارجيه ومكنستير اللي
هو مسؤول عن الامن القومي
ان احنا كنا بننظر الى خطه تركيا لضرب
جماعات داعش باقتاح يا شمال سوريا على
انها في حقيقه الامر ليس الا خطه لتطهير
العرقي للجماعات الكرديه اللي كانت بتحلم
به تركيا منذ سنوات
وانه اذا احنا سمحنا لهم بهذه الخطه فسوف
ينفذون هدفهم الخفي مش ضرب داعش ولكن
التصفيه العراقيه للقرد
بمباركه امريكا
لكن كمان كان في سبب ثاني جعلنا لا نتحمس
الى الاقتراح التركي وهو
التحفظ
ماتس وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان وقتها على
قدرات تركيا
في التعامل مع داعش وكانوا بيعتقدوا ان هم
ليس لديهم القدرات العسكريه للتعامل مع
داعش وبيقول انه رئيس الاركان طلبه ان يرى
القوات التي سوف تقوم بهذه العمليه اجلوا
سيارته عده مرات موحيا بان هم كانوا
بيحاولوا الاستعداد على عجل وانه لما ظهر
هذه القوات في نهايه المطاف جاء الى
الرئيس ترامب وقال لهم القوات التركيه لن
تستطيع التعامل مع داعش والقضاء عليها دون
مساعدته ضخمه جدا من القوات الامريكيه
وبالتالي قرر الاربعه مكنسه هو المسؤول عن
الامن القومي
وما تسوى رئيس الاركان بتقديم توصيل لرئيس
ترامب نعتمد على قصد بالفعل اعتماده
ان هم يحاربوا على الارض باعتبارهم ادرى
اكثر تنظيما انه عندهم دافع اكبر لان هما
بيحتلوا اراضيهم اللي هم داعش انه يعني
وانه يكفي جدا ان احنا نوفر لهم غطاء جوي
وبعض المساعدات وبيقول انه جاء المهمه
الثقيله لما اوكل الينا مهمه ابلاغ
الاتراك برفض مطلبهم والاعتماد على جسد
اللي هو عدوهم الاساسي بيقول لم ارى ابدا
في حياتي غضبا يتصاعد في غرفه كما رايت
المسؤولين الاتراك كانوا في حاله من الغضب
والحاج الشديد وغدره سريعا لكن بيقول انه
ثبت اننا كنا على حق وبحلول يناير 2019 تم
تحرير سوريا والعراق من العالم الاسود
للهيمنه للاسلاميه المتطرفه المذكرات في
حقيقه الامر مليئه بما يستحق القراءه
والتامل
ان تقرا تتامل تفهم شيء وان تصدقه شيء اخر
ليس بالضروره ان تصدق كل ما يقولونه لكن
يقين اصدق ما قال هذا الرجل في مذكراته
اننا نعيش في عالم شرير وموحش وقاسي
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله